6-Nate English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Maybe the only good thing about Covid lockdowns
was the return of wildlife to our towns and cities.
Birds, foxes and deer were seen in the streets close to people's homes.
Of course, rubbing shoulders with animals,
spending time with them is amazing.
But imagine a hungry African elephant stumbling into your garden
and eating your prize vegetables.
How would you stop it?
It sounds unlikely,
but that's exactly the problem faced by farmers in Africa.
Yes, as human populations increase,
while natural habitats decline,
people and animals are increasingly being forced to compete for space.
Wild animals can endanger humans when they break into their farms for food or water.
And people might be forced to attack or even kill these animals to defend their homes.
This situation, known as human wildlife conflict, is becoming more frequent.
But in this programme, we'll be hearing about ingenious farmers in Kenya
who are keeping their food safe from hungry wild animals.
And as usual, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary.
But first, I have a question for you, Beth.
Wailing around six tons of fully grown African elephant needs to eat a lot every day.
But how much exactly?
Is it a 50 kilograms of food per day,
b 100 kilograms of food per day,
or c 150 kilograms of food per day?
I'll guess an elephant eats 150 kilos of food a day.
Okay, Beth, we'll find out if that's the right answer at the end of the programme.
Victor and Donbi is food security officer for the wildlife charity Save the Elephants.
Victor works at Sarvo National Park in Kenya,
where he's often faced with wild elephants breaking into farms for food and water.
Here's Victor explaining more to Michael Koloki,
reporter for BBC World Service programme People Fixing the World.
The conflict usually varies.
What we experience here is during the crop season, the Diderain season,
that's where we usually have the crop rates.
The elephants will come here, lots of them, and the crop rate on the crops.
Can I ask you, where do these elephants come from?
So they come from those private lunches, national parks,
and they come to this community.
They are looking for where there is green pasture.
So they come to this community, where we have these nutritious foods,
you know, elephants, lawnmays, bins, and that is the crop that farmers usually farm.
So they come in those crops here and also looking for water.
Victor sounds very calm about this.
It's just a way of life for the people out here.
But elephants do spell big trouble for farmers.
A fully grown male elephant can weigh the same as six cars on top of each other.
It's easy to see how they can destroy crops and livelihoods.
Victor works in a national park, a large area of land
which is protected by the government because of its natural beauty, plants, or animals.
He explains that the elephants raid crops like mays and beans from farmers in the park.
To raid means to suddenly attack a place and steal from it.
These crop raids have become more frequent
because elephants are desperate to find water
and because the park lacks money to fix broken fences, which keep wild animals out.
Victor says the raids have become a way of life,
an activity that has become a regular thing in people's lives,
rather than something that happens only occasionally.
That's no problem if it's a fox in your rubbish bin,
but African elephants are as big as six cars on top of each other
and this spells trouble for the farmers.
If something spells trouble, it suggests that there may be problems in the future.
Fortunately, there's an unusual solution that's got people buzzing.
Bees.
Ancient Kenyan folklore says that elephants are scared of bees.
That's right. Elephants.
The world's biggest land mammal are scared of an insect the size of your thumbnail.
Victor's team install beehive fences to protect farmers crops.
Real bees work best, but even a recording of bees angrily buzzing
is enough to keep the elephants away.
Better yet, the bees also pollinate plants and even produce honey.
It's good news for the farmer, but I have to feel a little sorry for the elephants.
Yes, especially because they need to eat so much.
I think it's time to reveal the answer to my question, Beth.
You asked me how much food an elephant eats per day
and I guess it was 150 kilograms.
And that was the correct answer, well done.
A fully grown African elephant needs 150 kilograms of food per day.
Okay, let's recap the rest of the vocabulary we've learned in this program
about human wildlife conflict,
a phrase describing harmful encounters between humans and wild animals.
If you rub shoulders with someone, you meet them and spend time together.
To raid means to suddenly attack a place and steal something.
A national park is a large area of a country
which is protected by the government because of its natural beauty, plants or animals.
If you describe an activity as a way of life,
you mean that it's become a common or regular event for someone
rather than something that happens only occasionally.
And finally, when something spells trouble,
it suggests that there may be problems coming in the future.
Once again, our six minutes are up.
Goodbye for now.
Bye.